PROFESSOR: So in the majority
of cases of indoor spreading
that occur over the space
of hours or even a few days,
the Wells-Riley model
of slow incubation
where the number of
infectors is held constant
at the initial value, is a
reasonable approximation.
For COVID-19, the
incubation period
is estimated to be on the
order of several days.
For example, a
number of 5.5 days
is often quoted as an estimated
mean incubation period.
On the other hand,
in some cases there
are spreading events that
involve people interacting over
much longer periods
of time than that.
A famous example, which
is a little bit longer
than the time of
incubation, is the case
of the Diamond Princess
cruise ship, which
was quarantined in Yokohama
Port, Japan in early 2020
when it was detected that there
were a number of cases onboard.
The exact number wasn't
known because they
hadn't tested the
entire population,
but there were several cases.
And so they decided
to quarantine
the ship for 12 days.
And if you look at the number
of infections versus time
once they started
testing and felt
they had a good
sense of the numbers,
you can see that
it rose from value,
which we may estimate to be on
the order of 20 possible cases
initially.
And it rises, but in a
very non-linear fashion.
In fact, it starts to accelerate
and go steeper and steeper.
Now recall, the Wells-Riley
model cannot possibly predict
this behavior because if you
have a fixed number infectors,
then at first you have a certain
rate of transmission but it
always has to slow down because
if there's no new infections,
the same factors are running
out of susceptible people
to infect.
The number of susceptible
is going down,
and so you kind
of slowly saturate
until eventually you've
infected everybody,
when it's just one person or
a fixed number of people who
are basically transmitting at
a constant rate of infection
quanta to everybody else.
But that's not what happened.
In fact, it's a very steep rise.
It went-- just in
the last few days,
it jumped by several
hundred people.
And in fact, if
they hadn't stopped
the quarantine in 12 days--
there were 4,000
people on that ship.
I think 3,711.
I'll just mention I think
that was the number.
So way higher.
And you see how this
is accelerating.
If they'd gone with the
quarantine a couple more days,
they might have had
thousands of people infected.
So in fact, this is
an interesting warning
for quarantines,
that just cooping up
some people for 14 days
doesn't make everybody safe.
If many of those people are
susceptible and are not yet
infected, they can
become infected.
And many interesting
things about this incident
is that the people were not
in direct contact, obviously.
Thousands of people were not
six feet apart from each other.
They were often in
different rooms,
different floors of the ship.
And yet, very large
numbers became
infected in a short time.
So the important thing I'd like
to emphasize now coming back
to our SEI model is that this
sort of non-linear increase
can only be explained if you
have some accelerated spreading
due to new infected people.
And it makes sense
after about five days.
And we also don't know
when people got infected.
So those initially infected
people may have been
infected five days earlier.
So there may have been already
an increase in the number
infected people already at time
equals zero of the quarantine.
And so we should now account
also for the exposed people.
Those are people that may
not be showing symptoms yet,
but have been exposed enough
that they can then pass it on.
And so the rate of an
exposed person becoming
an infectious person is alpha.
And inverse of alpha
is that 5.5 days.
So that's the incubation time.
And this might be something
like 5.5 days for COVID-19.
But of course it can vary.
But it's roughly in that order.
And so it makes sense to
look at the Diamond Princess
and consider what would be
the effect of accounting
for incubation.
So these are
non-linear equations
that don't have a simple
solution to the full model.
But in the same way
the Wells-Riley model
is the limit of slow incubation,
where basically E stays zero
and basically you only
have infected people.
Now, we can consider
the opposite limit
of fast incubation.
So let's consider the opposite
limit of fast incubation.
And this would be alpha
t much greater than one.
So basically, we
want to make sure
that the t is much bigger
than the incubation time.
And as I said, the
incubation time
doesn't necessarily
start at time zero.
The infected people in
this case may have already
been infected five days earlier.
In fact, the cruise
ship had been going
for actually weeks before that.
So no one knows exactly
when the infection began.
So it may be even likely
that that was happening.
So let's consider the
fast incubation limit.
So what this then tells us is
that now the exposed portion
is roughly zero.
So if alpha is very quick,
then you pretty much quickly
go through the
exposed, and you end up
immediately being infected.
And so this is actually
a much simpler model
where the number of
susceptibles is just n minus I.
So there's no exposed
compartment anymore.
So the Wells-Riley
model in some sense
is the SE model, where there
are only exposed people
and susceptible, but the
number infected doesn't change.
This is really the
SI model, where
we don't worry about the
exposed compartment, OK?
So the equation we
want to solve then,
if we realize that
S is n minus I
is that dS dt is
minus beta of t SI.
So that's the same equation
I wrote down earlier.
But now let's substitute.
Let's derive an equation
for the number of infected.
So that will be from here, dI
dt will be beta of t times I.
And then S is n minus
I. Because again,
if we go straight through
the exposed fraction,
then basically this rate
of losing susceptibles
is equal to the rate of
creating new infected people.
Again, because n is fixed.
The number of people is fixed.
So dS dt is minus the dI dt.
So this is the equation
now that we can solve
for this limit of the model.
And fortunately, this is a
simple equation to solve.
It's a first order separable
differential equation.
So we can write
this as dI over I
times n minus I is
equal to beta of t dt.
On this side, I
can write this as--
I can factor out a one over n,
and write this as one over I
plus one over n minus I. So
when I combine these two,
I get In minus nine
in the denominator.
And the numerator, I get n
minus I plus I. So just get n.
But then it divides by
that n, so I do come back
to what I started with.
And this times dI.
And so now I can integrate
both sides this equation.
Take into account
the initial condition
is that at t equals zero, the
number of infectors is I0.
So basically, I can integrate
by going from zero to time, t.
And on this side, in
terms of the infectors,
I'm going from I0 to the
current number of infectors, I.
OK, so now we're ready to
integrate this equation.
So let's multiply the
n to the other side
and do the integrals.
So basically, the integral
of one over I is log I.
So we have log I minus
log of n minus I.
And that's because
there's a minus I there,
so that leads to a
minus sign out front.
On the other side, if I
multiply through by n,
I have n integral
from zero to t of beta
of t dt plus a constant
of integration.
The boundary condition that I
need is that I of zero is I0.
So a t equals zero,
this term vanishes,
and this expression must be
evaluated with I equal to I0.
So therefore, there
must be on this side
of the equation,
some constants log
of I0 minus log of n minus I0.
So now we satisfy the boundary
condition or initial condition
of t equals zero.
Now, I can also write this in
terms of the quanta emission
rate for the initial infectors,
which we defined earlier.
So for the Wells-Riley model,
we talked about writing q of t
is the number of quanta emitted
by the initial infector.
So if we just define it as
I zero times the integral
over time of beta
of t dt, this is
the sort of infection
quanta emitted
by the I0 initial infectors.
So if we take that here,
we can express the solution
a somewhat different way.
If I take an exponential
on both sides,
the difference of two logs
is the log of the ratio.
And when I exponentiate,
I get rid of the log.
So this side turns into I over
n minus I. And the other side,
we have from the similar
expression, I0 over n minus I0.
But times, now, the
exponential of--
well, if we want to express it
in terms of q0, it would be n.
And then this d beta dt
has a one over I0 q of t.
So this is the
solution in this case.
Now, if we look at early times--
and so then that would be
less than incubation time.
So if basically our alpha
t is much less than one--
so not much incubation
is occurred.
And basically during that time
I is approximately still equal
to I0.
So that would be kind of in
the early, early stages here
of this dynamics--
then we could write that
I of t is, well, from this
we could write it as n minus I0.
And then I0 times the time
interval of beta, or n minus I0
times q, or it's the number
of susceptibles times q of t.
So this is a result
that can come directly
from analyzing this expression.
We can also see it here,
that if I is not changing,
then we have I, n minus
I. And we can also
see this expression
here where we just
integrate both sides in time
to get to this equation here.
So it's basically the
same as the Wells-Riley
in an early time.
And that's an
interesting observation,
which is that there
is a universal sort
of small transmission limit
in both limits of this model.
And what that is,
if we take this--
at least for the
SEI model, if we
write how many exposed
plus infected relative
to the initial number
of infectors, OK?
So that is telling us how
many transmissions there
are, either to make
someone exposed
or to make them infectious
from the initial number
of infectors.
That at early times,
we get this same result
that we had before
because we got
the same thing for the
Wells-Riley model for E,
here it's for I. And
we find that this
is this what we call Rn, the
indoor transmission number.
Which is the initial number of
susceptibles times the number
of quanta transferred.
And in the case where if S0 were
equal to n minus one, and I0
were equal to one, this
would be n minus one integral
over t of beta dt.
That would be that case
that we talked about before
for the indoor
transmission number.
But more generally, it
would look like this.
So that is at early times,
before many transmissions
have happened.
It really doesn't matter
what's the details
of the model in terms of
the non-linear response.
So even if after a
longer amount of time
more and more
people get infected,
the initial moments are always
universal and are really
just governed by this
transmission rate
beta and the number of
susceptible people and number
of infectious people
initially in the room.
So it's kind of independent
of all these details here.
And so then to kind of
summarize that picture,
we could plot versus time here
what happens in terms of the--
so we have a rate
of transmission
where if I look at
the total number of
exposed plus
infected people, OK.
And then here's the total
number of people in the room, n.
So in the Wells-Riley
model, everyone's exposed,
but nobody becomes infectious.
And we know that we get this
kind of exponential relaxation
as we eventually run out
of susceptible people.
And the timescale for
that is beta inverse, OK.
And that gives you
the transmission time
for just a fixed
number of infectors
to slowly infect everybody else.
But in the case like
we described here
where we have some
non-linear acceleration,
that has to start out the same.
That's what I'm
trying to say here,
is the initial transmission
rate doesn't matter
if there is an incubation rate
until you reach the incubation
time.
So there's kind of
an alpha inverse
here, which is the
incubation time.
This one here is the
transmission time.
And at this time
scale, you start
to see an exponential increase
until it saturates basically
once all the transmission has
occurred because now there's
more and more infectious people.
And so this is the fast
incubation and slow incubation.
And this one is the Wells-Riley
model, which is widely used.
But if you're fitting spreading
data where there may actually
be some incubation going on,
and also potentially removal--
we could add another equation
for the removal of people.
We need to be careful on
how we fit data in order
to extract information about
the transmission rate, which
is what we're
interested in what we're
trying to interpret the data.
So maybe an important
conclusion from this
is that infection
quanta, this notion--
or the infection quantum, I
guess you can say, one of them.
Which is a quantity that
was introduced by Wells,
really based on this
Wells-Riley model,
is basically-- think of
this exponential relaxation,
and saying when let's say 63%
of people become infected,
that's what you say is
one infection quantum
has been transmitted to
each of those people.
Then really, it's
better defined--
I'll just write here it's
defined by the transmission
rate and not by the
number of people
that actually get infected.
So if you look at some
data like the Diamond
Princess or other data that
we're going to look at later,
you are seeing
spreading happening
and there could be
lots of contributions
to the number of people
that actually get sick.
For example, there could
be incubation going on.
So what's sometimes called
the secondary attack
rate is E plus I divided by S0.
So the secondary
attack rate is sort
of the fraction
of people that are
susceptible that got infected.
And the Wells-Riley would
say, when that 63% then you've
transmitted a quantum
to each of those people.
Whereas, as we see in the case
of the fast incubation model,
that's not how you would
interpret that data.
But on the other hand,
beta is well-defined.
It's just each person
is transferring quanta
at a certain rate
and has the potential
to infect other people.
Now, I don't want to
overstate the relevance
of this model for a particular
case like the Diamond Princess
cruise ship.
We'll come back to this later.
But just simply to
illustrate that it
has this kind of
non-linear feature
which is suggestive
of incubation
occurring and an increase in
the number of infected people.
And just to point out that
this sort of simple modeling
leads us to kind of a
universal expression
for the initial transmission
from the initial in factors
for each of them to transfer
to sort of one other,
which is this indoor
reproductive number.
And that's really what's
valid at the early times here.
And that's where we have
kind of a universal behavior.
And that's useful in
formulating safety guidelines,
which we will do next.